Yo, j'espère que vous allez bien!
J'espère que vous avez tous passé un très bon été.
Moi ça va.
Vous avez sûrement vu la vidéo sur le Népal.
Et il y a un moment, genre dans les 10 premiers jours,
quand j'étais avec les méditants et tout...
Il y a une pensée qui m'a traversée l'esprit c'était: "pourquoi
je ne resterai pas avec eux dans ce rythme de vie un petit peu monastique,
coupé de tout...
Pourquoi pas quoi?"
Et il y a deux choses : la première
c'est parce que
mes proches, ma famille, mes amis enfin et les gens que je vois...
je les apprécie et j'ai envie de continuer à les voir.
La seconde, c'est que je kiffe ma vie en société et c'est
notamment grâce à Youtube, grâce à ce que
je fais sur Youtube, c'est-à-dire en gros faire
des vidéos où je partage des choses
et vous vous les recevez et je trouve
ça génial quoi ! Je trouve ça cool parce que:
un, ça me plait de le faire et deux, c'est utile
et trois, potentiellement je pourrais
vivre de ça et ça serait vraiment top quoi.
Et je me suis dit, tu as cette chance
folle de pouvoir faire ce genre de trucs
et pourtant,
pourtant, attendez je vous montre :
pourtant depuis le début de l'année
tu as sorti genre, 10 vidéos, une vidéo par mois avec
(attendez la mise au point n'est pas tout à fait faite)
un seul coup de phil',
un seul ask... Tu as fais ça en dix mois quoi !
C'est dommage en fait, c'est juste dommage quoi !
Donc, en fait, j'aimerai :
produire plus, mais en même temps, c'est hors de question que je fasse un truc
qui soit moins bien, que je fasse un truc qui soit bâclé, que je fasse un truc qui ne me plaise pas.
Du coup, vu que ça à l'air compliqué d'augmenter la fréquence de production
sans changer le niveau,
je n'ai pas trop de solution quoi...
Ce n'est pas vrai.
En fait ce que je vais faire cette année, c'est ça: je vais produir beaucoup plus.
Je vous en parle avant, parce que si je produis pour personne,
ça n'a aucun intérêt, le but c'est que vous ça vous plaise aussi, que ça continue à vous plaire
et que vous kiffiez le truc, et que s'il y a des trucs que vous n'aimez pas
vous m'en faites part, et on converse là dessus.
J'ai réussi à me libérer du temps,
à m'entourer sur certains trucs, c'est hyper cool!
A priori, c'est hyper cool et
je vais aussi changer des trucs au niveau des formats.
Alors je vous explique: aujourd'hui il y a 4 formats sur ma chaîne.
Tiens, d'ailleurs, il manque une vidéo
que je n'ai pas mis dans ce format là.
Il y a les coups de phil', ok, que vous connaissez surtout.
Il y a Pop Up,
où je prends un truc de la pop-culture et j'en parle
de manière philosophique.
Il y a Cyrusly,
où je parle de news, d'ailleurs il en manque un aussi.
Et il y a Ask, où je répond aux questions que vous, vous m'envoyer.
D'accord ? Ça ce sont les 4 formats principaux de ma chaîne.
Ces 4 formats, ils vont être...
ils vont continuer à exister et ils vont être
au rythme de 1 par semaine.
C'est à dire que tous les jeudis
à 18 heures, il va y avoir un format que j'appelle "scripté",
ce sont des formats qui sont
écrits à l'avance, qui sont travaillés, où il y a des recherches et donc,
tous les jeudis à 18 heures, il y aura soit un coup de phil', soit un ask,
soit un Pop Up, soit un Cyrusly,
sachant qu'il y en a un de chaque,
chaque mois, d'accord?
En plus de ça, maintenant, il va y avoir
des formats qui sont non scriptés.
Alors les formats non scriptés c'est, par exemple,
un vlog.
Alors, pas comme ce que j'ai pu faire au Népal, parce que ça va être compliqué de faire
ça toutes les deux semaines.
Tu vois, idéalement, les vlogs ça serait toutes les deux semaines.
Mais ça peut être des trucs sur le
développement perso tu vois?
(oula pardon, j'ai touché mon micro)
Genre des trucs que moi j'apprends,
que je comprends et que je vous partage et là, du coup,
je n'ai pas besoin vraiment de script
parce que ça sort directement de là dedans quoi!
L'autre truc, l'autre format, c'est un format où j'ai besoin de vous.
C'est un format qu'en fait on va écrire ensemble.
L'idée c'est que je vous pose une question et vous;
vous y répondez, vous donnez des pistes de réflexion
et moi je partage vos pistes,
je les lis, je les commente,
on se marre avec,
et si possible avec un autre Youtuber.
Je vais vous donner un exemple, ça va être plus simple.
Je vais vous dire: "tu imagines si demain,
on est tous immortels?
Qu'est-ce qu'il se passerait?
Qu'est-ce qu'il se passerait concrètement dans notre société?" Ok?
Donc je vais donner un exemple: ce qui pourrait se passer c'est qu'on prendrait
plus des médicaments, du coup l'industrie
pharmaceutique va se casser la figure et du coup, il va y avoir grave du chômage dans ce secteur-là.
Sauf que, ils ont telles compétences, du coup ils vont essayer de se réinsérer
dans tel truc...
Je n'en sais rien tu vois, et donc c'est assez précis, ok? Et là j'ai choisi une piste.
J'aurai pu en choisir...
juste y'en a des milliers!
Il y en a une infinité quasiment. Et donc l'idée c'est que, vous, vous essayez de trouver des
trucs, et faites vous plaisir genre..
ça peut être aussi des trucs un peu marrant, des trucs un peu drôle et ça peut
être ça peut être aussi des trucs hyper recherchés genre
vraiment allez-y, je vous fait confiance là dessus,
à chaque fois que je vous ai sollicité vous avez su produire de de très belles choses
donc il n'y a pas de problème! Donc, du coup,
je vais vous balancer un thème pour la
prochaine, pour le prochain "Imagine si"
que je vais faire, normalement, avec Léo de la chaîne Dirty Biology.
Si vous ne connaissez pas, je vous le met en description c'est une très cool chaîne, allez-y.
kool shen !
Nan parce que kool shen c'est un rappeur dans NTM... Bref.
Donc la question c'est : t'imagines si...
Nan, je vais la lire bien pour être sûr qu'il n'y a pas de quiproquo.
T'imagines s'il n'y avait plus d'hommes,
plus de femmes,
mais que tous les êtres humains
étaient d'un troisième sexe,
un sexe unique. Et donc ça c'est la question que je vous pose.
Balancez dans les commentaires, du coup, toutes les
pistes de réflexion qu'il y a autour.
Forcément c'est une question
qui est assez courte, du coup.
Il est possible que vous demandiez, "ouais mais
d'un coup on devient...
on passe à cet état d'un coup ou cet état a toujours existé?
Franchement à vous de voir. Vous mettez les présupposés
que vous voulez
autour de la question,
parce que ce qui est intéressant c'est
aussi de voir, comment la question peut
être interprétée,
qu'est-ce qui va changer suivants les présupposés de cette question là.
Genre c'est vraiment... ça dépend de vous, ça dépend
de ce sur quoi vous avez envie de réfléchir en fait.
Donc je pense que ça peut être un super concept, ça peut être très cool, ça peut être très drôle.
L'idée c'est donc de lui, le faire une
une semaine sur deux, donc alterner avec les vlogs et tout ça, ça serait le dimanche.
D'accord? Donc le jeudi,
18 heures, on a une vidéo scriptée, le dimanche, il y aura ces vidéos qui sont un peu plus détente.
Voilà! C'était vraiment le plus important, ce que je voulais vous dire.
Je ne vais pas m'éterniser.
Exemple de vlog: par exemple, dans deux semaines je fais un Tedx à Valenciennes.
Donc, si vous me suivez sur facebook,
vous l'avez sûrement vu,
et bah ça peut être super vlog
de comment ça se passe
derrière un Tedx.
Voilà!
Je crois que j'ai tout dit, ça me fait grave plais' de vous annoncer tout ça.
On se retrouve donc jeudi 18 heures et ce sera un coup de phil', ça fait bien
longtemps qu'il n'y a pas eu de coup de phil'.
Ça sera sur Schopenhauer,
Et j'espère...
j'espère vraiment qu'il vous plaira.
NAMASTE